[Música]
ya son más de 40 los muertos que dejan
las inundaciones provocadas por aida los
remanentes de esa tormenta sorprendieron
al noreste de eeuu con un nivel de
lluvias calificado como histórico por
las autoridades nueva york nueva jersey
y pensilvania los estados más afectados
tenemos informe desde la gran manzana
regreso a las clases en francia más de
12 millones de estudiantes volvieron a
las aulas en el territorio galo en medio
de los temores a su impacto en la
situación de la pandemia hay
preocupación por la presencia de la
variante delta
el mundo espera la formación del nuevo
gobierno talibán los islamistas aseguran
que darán este paso en los próximos días
en france24 tenemos los últimos detalles
de esta noticia desde kabul con nuestro
equipo sobre el terreno
momento de actualizar la información en
france 24 gracias por seguir con nuestra
señal
yo soy con bucles al menos 40 muertos es
el saldo que dejan los vestigios de la
tormenta aeda en la costa noreste de
eeuu un nivel inusual de lluvias
torrenciales sorprendió a los estados de
nueva york nueva jersey y pensilvania
las autoridades han calificado estas
precipitaciones como históricas el
propio metro de la gran manzana se vio
sobrepasado por la irrupción del agua y
con la ampliación de estos detalles está
nuestra corresponsal en nueva york'
mamen sala
si de esas víctimas mortales 13 hay que
lamentar las aquí en nueva york entre
ellas una niña de tan sólo dos años y
desgraciadamente esa cifra total podría
seguir aumentando a medida que avanzan
las labores de rescate porque todavía
hay mucha gente atrapada en vehículos y
en casas hay hogares que se han
convertido en auténticas trampas
mortales porque el agua entraba en ellas
y era más peligroso quedarte quedarse
dentro que salir los servicios de
emergencia trabajan todavía a estas
horas a contrarreloj en una tarea que no
es nada fácil porque hay todavía cientos
de carreteras cortadas solamente en
pensilvania más de 380 muchas de ellas
vías principales se han convertido en
auténticos ríos y para circular por
ellas hay que hacerlo con barcas esto
está dificultando las labores de
socorrer a las personas que se han
quedado atrapadas hay más de 150 mil
clientes sin suministro eléctrico y las
empresas ya han dicho que tardarán en
restablecer la energía porque los
destrozos son muchos y muy cuantiosos no
se veía una tormenta así desde hacía
muchos años en todo este área
tri-estatal
nueva york pensilvania y nueva jersey la
gobernadora de nueva york la recién
estrenada gobernadora de nueva york hoy
decía que se trata de inundaciones
históricas y que hablar de algo sin
precedentes es quedarse corto ha pedido
ayuda al presidente job aid en que hoy
mismo en una declaración ante la nación
ha dicho que aportará todo el apoyo
federal que sea necesario y ha dicho que
ahora mismo se están centrando en cuatro
áreas una restablecer el suministro
eléctrico a restablecer el suministro de
gasolina también que en sitios como
luisiana empiezan ya a escasear a ayudar
y apoyar económicamente a las personas
afectadas y a los pequeños negocios y
dar cobijo para esta noche y para las
siguientes a todas aquellas personas que
lo necesiten si algo en algo han
coincidido todos los gobiernos
nacionales y locales que hemos podido
escucharlo a lo largo del día de hoy es
que el cambio climático está detrás de
estos terribles hechos y que es algo
cada vez más amenazante y más común nos
quedamos en eeuu y en donde hay varias
voces de rechazo frente a la ley de
texas que prohíbe el aborto más allá de
las seis semanas una de ellas es la del
propio presidente yo bailé quien afirmó
que estando desata un caos
constitucional las reacciones en el
siguiente informe
yo bailé en relación a la decisión de
los jueces del tribunal supremo con una
bici ética declaración para el
presidente la decisión de dejar que
tejas promulgó una ley de aborto muy
restrictiva
es un ataque sin precedentes a los
derechos constitucionales de las mujeres
esta decisión crea un caos
inconstitucional e insulta al estado de
derecho
el mandatario demócrata asegura que su
administración actuara rápidamente para
garantizar que las mujeres de texas
tengan un acceso seguro y legal al
aborto en el estado conservador muchas
mujeres han temido durante mucho tiempo
este endurecimiento de la ley tenemos
una pandemia que hace estragos fallos en
la red una tormenta que mató a gente
hemos tenido todos estos problemas aquí
en texas y sin embargo están ocupados
prohibiendo el aborto a partir del
miércoles posiblemente las mujeres de
texas ya no podrán abortar después de
las 6 semanas de embarazo salvo en casos
de peligro para la salud de la mujer
ahora más del 85% de los abortos se
realizan después de ese momento según la
planificación familiar aún más polémico
es el hecho de que el texto deja la
ejecución de la ley en manos de los
ciudadanos
hasta 10.000 dólares por denunciar
cualquier recurso al aborto tardío así
como a los médicos que lo realizan
tenemos derecho a demandar a las mujeres
y a las personas que las puedan ayudar a
abortar esto es completamente absurdo
el derecho al aborto en eeuu está
garantizado desde 1973 tras el famoso
caso de robo contra white pero ahora
mismo parece claramente amenazado por
algunos funcionarios electos
republicanos que están decididos a
endurecer la legislación en un momento
en el que el tribunal supremo de eeuu
está compuesto mayoritariamente por
jueces conservadores
vamos a francia porque desde este jueves
más de 12 millones de estudiantes y
cerca de 900.000 docentes volvieron a
las clases aunque el presidente emmanuel
macrón defiende esta vuelta a la
escolaridad presencial como una victoria
hay temor por el impacto que eso pueda
tener en la pandemia con la presencia de
la variante del tap actualmente cerca de
la mitad de la población entre 12 y 17
años en francia cuenta ya con su esquema
de vacunación al completo
seguimos en este país porque
precisamente el presidente manuel macro
me ha prometido que su gobierno ayudará
a la ciudad de marsella a hacer frente a
la delincuencia y la pobreza que sufre
la región con la proximidad de las
elecciones presidenciales en abril de
2022 la segunda ciudad más grande del
territorio y sus históricos problemas
sociales están en la agenda política del
mandatario
recibido entre abucheos el coche del
presidente francés se detiene para
visitar una escuela en los barrios del
norte de marsella una de las zonas más
desfavorecidas de francia esta escuela
como muchas otras de la ciudad está en
mal estado y emanuel macrón ha prometido
ayudar al plan del alcalde para
renovarlas este es el gimnasio de la
escuela y puede verlo por usted mismo en
qué estado se encuentra a pesar de
nuestros mejores intentos de limpiarlo
en previsión de la visita del
presidencias a ocho meses de las
elecciones presidenciales marsella está
en el radar de macrón en el segundo día
de su visita de tres días dijo que era
el deber de la nación ayudar a mejorar
las condiciones de la ciudad plagada de
pobreza y delincuencia derivada de las
drogas
hablamos mucho de la urgencia de la
situación de seguridad algunos dirían
demasiado porque no es nuevo pero nunca
deberíamos acostumbrarnos pero si ve
hacia la situación en los barrios de
marsella se trata de una lucha contra el
narcotráfico que debemos combatir pero
excepto debemos llevar a cabo una
verdadera casa una política de acoso a
los traficantes tanto aquí sobre el
terreno como hasta los jefes de la red
de tráfico el extranjero
de macrón dijo que además de los 150
millones de euros ya prometidos a la
policía de la ciudad 200 agentes
adicionales serán desplegados el próximo
año y se instalarán quinientas cámaras
de vigilancia a los barrios más
peligrosos de marsella también prometió
más dinero para la renovación de
viviendas y hospitales y la ampliación
del transporte público macrón espera
evitar la competencia de su contrincante
presidencial de extrema derecha marine
lepén que se espera se haga su campaña
con una plataforma de ley y orden así
como de la izquierda que pide más
recursos para los servicios sociales
vamos a organizar en donde este jueves
un grupo de unas 50 mujeres salió a
protestar en era la tercera ciudad más
grande del país con su rostro
descubierto sin burka estas mujeres
defendieron su derecho a trabajar y
estudiar también denuncian la nula
participación que tienen en el nuevo
régimen talibán que ya ha reconocido que
será poco probable ver a mujeres en el
nuevo ejecutivo del país
y precisamente el enviado especial de
france 24 en afganistán cyril payán nos
cuenta lo que se sabe de la formación de
un nuevo gobierno de los islamistas
si nos basamos en los rumores de las
calles tendremos este nuevo gobierno
dentro de poco esto es lo que sugiere el
alto responsable de ramadí uno de los
portavoces de la línea dura de la
jefatura del talibán alessio todo el
sexismo a mi modo es cristian que sería
una cuestión de horas o de días lo que
se dice también es que la gran jefatura
espiritual del talibán y la acusada que
está recluido en la clandestinidad
décadas desde hace mucho tiempo estaría
en camino a kabul o ya estarían kabul
cabe mencionar que es un hombre secreto
no existe ni una fotos no sabemos cuál
es su aspecto pero materializaría la
formación del primer gobierno del
emirato islámico de afganistán de el
talibán que tomó el poder hace unos diez
días eso significa que el talibán debe
actuar con velocidad primero para
ofrecer garantías a la comunidad
internacional el país está al borde de
la quiebra la situación social la
situación humanitaria no hay más
efectivo en la calle los bancos están
cerrados las administraciones no
funcionan también se trata de ofrecer
garantías si la población no es la misma
que cuando el talibán estaba en el poder
en 1996 está mucho más educada se
emancipó durante 20 años y es cierto que
el talibán tuvo que actuar con velocidad
de ofrecer garantías a la población
entonces podemos esperar un gobierno
mañana orizaba
en noticias de la región del presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador
anunció que quiere insistir a su
homólogo estadounidense joe biden con su
propuesta para otorgar visas de trabajo
temporales a migrantes entre 7
americanos y mexicanos dice and block
que enviará una carta a bailén para que
de esta manera se pueda atacar de raíz
es la migración irregular
la semana próxima más tardar
le envío una carta
porque no podemos sólo estar
deteniendo reteniendo
hay que atender las causas
la gente no sale
por gusto
cuba el único país de américa latina que
desarrolla vacunas contra el cob 19
anunció que presentará a sus tres
candidatas ante la organización mundial
de la salud el gobierno de la isla ya
autorizó el uso de emergencia de sus
tres potenciales vacunas y según
funcionarios cubanos esperan ahora
comenzar intercambios con la o ms para
obtener el visto bueno definitivo
las autoridades sanitarias de méxico
confirmaron este jueves novecientos
noventa y tres muertes más por la
pandemia de kobe 19 el ministerio de
salud también registró 18 mil 138 nuevos
contagios en las últimas 24 horas ayer
miércoles el país había registrado un
récord de fallecidos con
2.777 en total méxico lamenta la muerte
de más de 261 mil personas y el número
de contagios supera los 3,3 millones
en brasilia está en marcha la aplicación
de la tercera dosis de la vacuna contra
el 19 para adultos mayores ciudades como
salvador y são luís ya realizan este
proceso desde el lunes y desde el
miércoles la dosis de refuerzo se aplica
ya también en río de janeiro
sólo uno de cada solo uno de cada cuatro
países en el mundo cuenta con políticas
para apoyar a los pacientes que sufren
de demencia ya los familiares de estos
según la organización mundial de la
salud más de 55 millones viven con esta
enfermedad neurológica una cifra que en
2023 podría alcanzar los 78 millones en
donde el 15 de los ministros de salud de
varios países acordaron un plan global
contra la demencia que incluye el
diagnóstico temprano y brindar ayudas
pero los objetivos previstos a 10 años
no se están cumpliendo
en noticias de áfrica la policía
nigeriana anunció la liberación de 5 de
los 73 estudiantes que habían sido
secuestrados el miércoles en los
alrededores de la localidad de maradona
al noroeste del país fue un rapto masivo
que se produjo cuando hombres
fuertemente armados ingresaron a una
escuela y se llevaron los alumnos las
autoridades estatales ordenaron el
cierre de las escuelas primarias y
secundarias de manera temporal mientras
avanza la búsqueda del resto de los
escolares
vamos con la segunda jornada el festival
de cine de venecia y hablamos de una
obra que combina tragedia y deporte es
el largometraje titulado fue la mano de
dios'
del director italiano paolo sorrentino
quien presentó este jueves una cinta
autobiográfica que transcurre en una
turbulenta nápoles su ciudad natal y que
está dedicada del astro del fútbol del
argentino diego armando maradona
vamos con deportes porque avanza la
séptima jornada de las eliminatorias de
la conmebol para el mundial de
qatar-2022 en imágenes lo más destacado
de estas jornadas el arranque de en el
arranque de sus partidos las selecciones
de bolivia y colombia repartieron puntos
en la ciudad de la paz los cafeteros
dirigidos por reinaldo rueda se
adelantaron en el marcador gracias a el
gol de roger martínez al minuto 69 sin
embargo bolivia dirigida por césar
farías empató las acciones sobre el
minuto 83 tras un disparo de larga
distancia de fernando saucedo y para
repasar más de estos marcadores veamos
cómo avanza el resto de la jornada el
cuadro órgano ya 2 a 0 a paraguay y ya
está en juego el partido entre venezuela
y argentina más adelante tenemos los
choques entre perú y uruguay y chile y
brasil
gracias por estar con nosotros la
información continúa en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]